الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا طالت طبيعتها
مختلف فئات الشعب الاوكراني ولعل اكثر
المتضررين هم الفئه الاضعف الاطفال تقرير
امريكي صادر عن مركز يايل للابحاث تحدث عن
ان روسيا تحتجز اكثر من سته الاف طفل
اوكراني فيما قد يرقى الى جريمه حرب بحسب
المركز البحث قال ان احتجاز الاطفال
الاوكرانيين في روسيا يهدف الى اعاده
تثقيفهم وتشكيلهم وفق اهداف وغايات روسيه
مركز جياي للابحاث اشار الى انه منذ بدء
الحرب قبل عام يتم نقل اطفال لا تتجاوز
اعمار بعضهم اربعه اشهر الى 43 معسكر في
انحاء روسيا من اجل التعليم الوطني
والتثقيف العسكري والمتعلق بالجيش الروسي
العربيه التقت الباحث في المركز وهو
النيثنيل ريموند المدير التنفيذي لمختبر
البحوث الانسانيه بجامعه ييل الذي تو ان
يكون رقم الاطفال المخطوفين اكبر من
المذكور والمتوقع حتى الان
لدينا عدد كبير من المواقع قيد البحث الان
نحن نحقق فيما يقرب من 43 موقعا ونشعر
بثقه كبيره بان عدد الاطفال المخطوفين
اعلى بشكل كبير بالاضافه لذلك نعتقد ان
الرقم سته الاف الذي ذكرناه يضاف اليه
15,000ا اعلنت الحكومه الاوكرانيه واعتقد
ان الرقم سيزداد في الايام والاسابيع
المقبله
اضاف ان روسيا تنتهك بشكل واضح اتفاقيه
جنائذ الرابعه حول معامله المدنيين خلال
الحرب وقال ان تقرير المركز اشبه بجرص
انذار حيال الوضع المتعلق بخطف الاطفال
الاوكرانيين
ما ساقوله لروسيا هو اقراوا اتفاقيه جنيف
التي انتم طرف فيها تحضر الاتفاقيه
الرابعه صراحه نقل الاطفال الى بلد يعتبر
طرفا في نزاع ببلد اخر وينص على نقلهم الى
دوله او طرف ثالث بالاضافه الى ذلك انت
بحاجه لتسجيل الاطفال والسماح لهم
بالاتصال بدويهم والسماح للمراقبين
الدوليين بزيارتهم في الوقت الحالي بغض
النظر عن الدور الانساني الذي تحول روسيا
انها تؤديه الا انها لم تلتزم بالقانون
خلال هذه الفتره
تقرير مركز ياي للابحاث طلب بهيئه محايده
يسمح لها بالوصول الى المعسكرات الروسيه
وبان توقف روسيا على الفور اجراءات تبني
اطفال اوكرانيين وفصل الباحث في المركز
في مقابله مع العربيه المناطق التي يتم
منها اختطاف الاطفال الاوكرانيين نتابع
جزءا اخر من هذه المقابله مع طلال الحاج
المجموعه رقم واحد هم بالدرجه الاولى من
دونسك ويشكلون الاغلبيه هم من الاطفال
الذين يكونوا اباؤهم في كثير من الاحيان
موظفين محليين ويقال لهم ان بالامكان ان
لا يرسلوا ابنائهم للقتال وبدلا من ذلك
يرسلون الى معسكرات لا يعودون منها
المجموعه الثانيه يطلب الروس اجلائهم
وتحديدا من خاركيب والزابوريجيا وماريوبول
وخيرسون وكل هؤلاء الاطفال كانوا في
مؤسسات الدوله الاوكرانيه في فتره ما قبل
الغزواني وفي المقابله ايضا دعا مركز جياي
الابحاث الى ان تفرض مختلف الدول عقوبات
على الجهات الروسيه المتورطه في احتجاز او
اختطاف الاطفال الاوكرانيين
والقيام بارسالهم الى روسيا
الاتحاد الاوروبيه يتبنى عقوبات ضد
الافراد المتورطين في هذا البرنامج الروسي
واعتقد انه من المحتمل ان تتخذ دول اخرى
مسارا مشابها وهو ما امله نرى ايضا ضغطا
لايجاد نظام تسجيل دولي موحد لهؤلاء
الاطفال واعتقد انه يجب ان تسال كل دوله
عضو في الامم المتحده ما الذي تفعله
للتاكد من محاسبه اولئك الذين يشاركون في
سلسله القياده الروسيه ويجب ان نضمن
قدرتنا على احصاء هؤلاء الاطفال ومعرفه
كيفيه التعامل مع هذا العدد الكبير
نهايه الاسبوع الماضي عقد مجلس الامن
الدوليه جلسه في الذكرى الاولى لحرب
اوكرانيا ومن بين الملفات التي كانت
مطروحه موضوع الاطفال المختطفين من
اوكرانيا واولئك المرحلين الى روسيا
خلال العام المنصرم قتلت روسيا عشرات
الالاف من الاوكرانيين من نساء ورجال
واطفال واقتلعت اكثر من 13 مليون شخص من
ديارهم ودمرت اكثر من نصف شبكه الطاقه
الاوكرانيه او قصفت اكثر من 700 مستشفى
واختطفت على الاقل سته الاف من الاطفال
الاوكرانيين وقامت بترحيلهم الى روسيا
تنفذ الان في اوكرانيا على الارجح اكبر
عمليه اختطاف اطفال تدار برعايه دوله في
التاريخ الحديث
هؤلاء الاطفال يجب اعادتهم الى العائلات
او الاوصيع القانونيين دون تاخير وسيظل
الاثر الماساوي لعمليات النقل والترحيل
هذه على الاطفال الاوكرانيين للاجيال
القادمه
روسيا ردت على التقارير التي تحدثت عن
احتجازها اطفالا اوكرانيين عبر بيان
لسفارتها في واشنطن البيان قال ان روسيا
استقبلت اطفالا اجبروا على الفرار مع
اسرهم من القصف في اوكرانيا واضافت
السفاره ان روسيا تبذل قصار جهدها للحفاظ
على القصر مع اسرهم وفي حالات غياب او
وفاه الوالدين والاقارب يوضع الايتام تحت
وصايه
واعتبرت روسيا اجراءاتها بمثابه انقاذ
ايتام او نقل الاطفال لرعايه طبيه قبل ذلك
كشف التقارير غربيه عن ان مساعدين للرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين انخرطوا عن كثب في
عمليه نقل الاطفال الاوكرانيين الى عوائل
روسيه خصوصا ماريال فوفا بيلوفا المفوضه
الرئاسيه لحقوق الطفل وقد ظهرت المسؤوله
الروسيه في مقاطع مصوره في اكتوبر الماضي
وهي تنزل من طائره عسكريه برفقه ثلاثه
وخمسين طفلا اوكرانيا قالت حينها انهم
ايتام تم انقاذهم من مناطق الحرب في
دومباس شرق اوكرانيا وان رئيس اقليم
دانياسك الموالي لروسيا طلب اجلاء الاطفال
الى مناطق امنه انذاك اعلن الكرملين ان
هؤلاء الاطفال سينضمون الى 350 طفلا اخرين
تم تبنيهم ليبداوا حياه جديده في روسيا
وبشكل عام تختلف التقديرات حول اعداد
الاطفال الاوكرانيين الذين نقلتهم روسيا
الى مناطقها والارقام تتراوح بين سته الاف
طفل وعشرات الالاف منهم اذا ما اخذ بعين
الاعتبار نشاط روسيا ووكلائها في المناطق
التي يسيطرون عليها في الشرق الاوكراني